a sea of fire on the edge of the Afghan  capital local media say the insurgents  fired rockets at the trucks which  supplied fuel for NATO horses  firefighters battled the planes for  hours the Taliban has claimed  responsibility for the attack it's an  explosive end to the relative quiet  following the presidential run-off last  month the nearly 200 tankers were parked  on the outskirts of kabul drivers looked  on in horror tabarnac evocative uka it  was the Taliban they were dressed in  uniform which is why we didn't realize  what was happening they set the tankers  on fire and shot at drivers trying to  save the trucks mortar jalenka poder de  Secoya the attack comes as NATO prepares  to pull out of the country by the end of  the year and before the preliminary  results of the presidential runoff are  due to be announced an election the  Taliban had vowed to disrupt